princeville pare-feu mélomanes jacques
brunet de terrebonne voulez participer à
tout prix à la première journée du
disque québécois
j'ai vu ça sur mon fils sur facebook je
venais aujourd'hui à mourir exprès pour
eux mais acheter un disque avec moi
cette journée du disque québécois et
mini sciatique d'un agent d'artistes et
musiciens de montréal rapidement son
message a été entendu
un peu partout dans la province je pense
pas que j'aurais vraiment fait ce à une
époque avant les réseaux sociaux
évidemment oui on essaye d'encourager
les gens à acheter un album qui est
qu'aujourd'hui mais surtout c'était de
créer une discussion tout le monde
la musicienne salomé leclerc qui compte
trois albums en dix ans de carrière
applaudi l'initiative qu'à la vente de
disques va mal
[Musique]
les temps ont changé beaucoup moins
depuis dix ans j'ai remarqué une énorme
diminution de ventes d'albums et là
c'est autant magasin car quand un
spectacle aussi parce que je traîne
encore mon bac de dix piges et c'est
encore d'enfants et je dirai ce qui
marche le plus en ce moment c'est les
vignes et les musiciens d'ici ont besoin
de toute l'aide offerte
car les ventes d'albums sont en chute
libre en 2009 il s'est vendu plus de 5
millions d'albums québécois en 2018
en incluant le numérique c'était deux
millions trois cent soixante neuf mais
l'album et ne comptez pas sur la musique
en continu pour faire vivre les
musiciens québécois est grosso modo
sommet tous les services ensembles pour
avoir 5000 dollars de revenus on doit
être jouée en streaming un million de
fois et quand je parle de 5000 $ s'est
pas directement à l'artiste mais à
l'ensemble du milieu c'est-à-dire
distributeurs maison dix producteurs et
artistes fait un calcul rapide chaque
écoute en continu d'une chanson rapporte
en moyenne un demi-cent jacques brunel
lui s'est rabattu sur le bon vieux
vinyle dont les ventes progressent pour
encourager nos musiciens
finalement vous êtes garé là oui j'ai
ouï je m'étais dit que j'en achèterais
plus avant noël mais vu que c'est la
journée pour le québec
j'en ai acheté j'en ai acheté deux ici
luis est dépouillée mais radio-canada
montréal